[Music]
first settled by Vikings this Flemish
city grew into a nexus of medieval trade
routes it has withstood economic
downturns and world wars and remains one
of the best-preserved examples of a
medieval European settlement bruger also
known as Bruges is located in Belgium's
Flanders region the town's strategic
connection to the North Sea made it into
a major commercial centre merchants from
around the continent met here bringing a
hodgepodge of languages and cultural
influences the city grew into a hub of
art and architecture during their
Renaissance it was the center of the
Flemish primitives painting school and
home to master artists like Yann Van
Eyck and Hans Memling however the city's
fortunes
and flowed throughout the centuries by
the 1500s Antwerp had supplanted Bruges
as a trading centre
[Music]
and just three hundred years later
Bruges was one of Europe's poorest
cities today Bruges has a new lease on
life
as a tourist destination guests from
around the world flocked to the city to
float down its historic canals and under
its picturesque stone bridges many of
the original gothic structures remain
intact including the imposing 13th
century belfry overlooking the town
square enterprising visitors can climb
366 steps for a panoramic view of the
city the medieval structures blend
harmoniously with the neo gothic
buildings and facades constructed in the
late 19th century preserving the town's
old-world atmosphere the city has its
own international airport and it's a
short drive from nearby Brussels late
spring and early fall are the best times
to visit this charming Flemish town
[Music]
[Music]